i heard your girls and bridesmaids went
to a strip club for
research oh yeah is that true we did
yeah kristen wiig
hired a party bus or a huge bus you know
and we were all got on and there was
like
a bar and this is pre-co but obviously
this was 10 years ago
and um we drove yeah we went to this
strip club in la and it was yeah most of
the women in the audience were like
getting married or like bridal parties
so it was like a lot of that little like
throwing off like what do you call it
when the like
you're on a hens night well you don't
say that here bachelorette bachelor
that's what we're saying i'm going to
say that from the hens night yes
all the hands the hands so it was
hysterical it was hysterical it was a
great bonding night and this was all
christian week you know she's completely
she's just so creative and eccentric and
wonderful and
loving what a team building exercise it
was a very team building exercise i got
on stage at one point and uh yeah
but i was wearing a very expensive
blouse and he was very oily so i was a
little bit like
oh this is like this costs a lot of
money want more fun stuff
i thought so check out these videos
floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure